♪ ♪
>> Katie: PRESIDENT BIDEN
STUMBLES AND DEMOCRATS LOOK FOR
AN ALTERNATIVE, TRYING TO REHAB
KAMALA HARRIS, AND BLAMING
JOE BIDEN FOR THE TROUBLES OF
HIS VICE PRESIDENT WITH THE
HEADLINE KAMALA HARRIS IS STUCK.
ADDING SHE HAS HAMPERED BY
MR. BIDEN'S UNPOPULARITY TO BE
SURE, BUT SHE HAS ALSO NOT
BECOME A SUCCESSFUL PUBLIC FACE
ON ANY MAJOR ISSUE.
THAT HAS BEEN STUCK IN A
POLITICAL ROLE TROUBLING FOR
ANYONE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
STABILITY AND CONTINUITY OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
BUT REALITY CHECK, KAMALA HARRIS
HAS ONLY HERSELF TO BLAME FOR
HOW THE PUBLIC PERCEIVES HER TO
CHECK OUT THIS AWKWARD MOMENT.
>> SO WHEN I THINK ABOUT WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO ADDRESS MAYOR AND
WHAT ULTIMATELY DOES SO OFTEN
FALL ON THE SHOULDERS OF OUR
MAYORS TO ADDRESS ON A COMMUNITY
LEVEL.
>> Jessica: I CANNOT IMAGINE
WHY SHE WOULD BE UNPOPULAR, WHAT
HAS BEEN HANDED.
>> Jesse: I WILL TAKE AN
ARTIFICIAL STANCE, BECAUSE I
WANT TO BLAME JOE A LITTLE BIT.
JOE SHOULD BE GROOMING, COMING
OUT IN THE PERVERTED WAY, I SEE
YOUR FACE.
I AM TALKING ABOUT THE WAY THEY
MAY BE EISENHOWER GROOMED NIXON,
DELEGATING A LOT OF MAJOR STUFF.
SO HE HAD A HEART ATTACK,
JOE BIDEN, KAMALA HARRIS NEEDS
TO BE ABLE TO STEP IN AND TAKE
KNEE-JERK DECISIONS, WAS IT TRIM
IN THE CAYMAN OFFICE IN HIS
FIRST MONTH HE HAD TO DECIDE
WHETHER TO DROP THE A BOMB ON
JAPAN OR DO THE BERLIN AIRLIFT,
HE HAD MAJOR DECISIONS.
I DON'T THINK THAT KAMALA HARRIS
COULD COME IN AND DO ANYTHING.
SO SHE IS SUPPOSED TO HAVE LUNCH
WITH JOE BIDEN.
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE LUNCH
ANYMORE.
SHE IS SUPPOSED TO BE HAVING
LUNCH WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE, A STANDING THING FOR
MANY, MANY PRESIDENCIES AND
WHAT'S HIS FACE OVER IT STATES
ICED HER OUT.
SO JOE HAS ONLY GIVEN ARE THINGS
THAT HE DID NOT WANT TO DEAL
WITH, HE HAS NOT GIVEN HER ANY
POSITION WHERE SHE CAN SHAPE
POLICY.
HE ONLY PICKED HER BECAUSE SHE
WAS THE FEMALE OF COLOR AND THEN
ONCE HE GOT ELECTED HE KICKED
HER TO THE CURB.
SO HE SHOULD BE GROOMING HER TO
BE THE HEIR APPARENT AND HE HAS
FAILED TO DO SO.
WAS THAT GOOD?
>> Katie: THAT WAS PRETTY
GOOD, I LIKE THAT.
SO JUST CUT, IT IS TRUE THAT
VICE PRESIDENTS TYPICALLY GET
PORTFOLIOS THAT ARE HARDER
POLITICALLY SO THE PRESIDENT CAN
BE MORE POPULAR, BUT THAT IS NOT
WORKING FOR JOE BIDEN, SO IT IS
AN UNFAIR OR IS SHE NOT RISING
TO THE OCCASION?
>> Jessica: I THINK IT IS A
COMBINATION OF ALL OF IT AND
JOE BIDEN HAS A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE OF GETTING A
PORTFOLIO, IT'S A THANKLESS JOB
BEING VP.
YOU ARE THERE FOR WHAT CAN BRING
TO THE TICKET.
BARACK OBAMA FAMOUSLY DID NOT
WANT JOE BIDEN TO BE AS VP AND
THEY SAID, NO, THIS IS THE RIGHT
PERSON IF YOU WANT TO WIN, AND
THEY ENDED UP BFFs BY THE END
OF IT.
>> Katie: ARE THEY STILL
BFFs?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jessica: I THINK THAT THEY
STILL LOVE EACH OTHER, BUT HE
DID PICK SOMEONE WHO DROPPED OUT
BEFORE IOWA.
THIS WAS NOT SOMEONE WHO MADE IT
TO THE END OR HAD A DISTINCT
COHORT THAT WAS VERY WIDESPREAD.
IT WAS VERY TARGETED AND
SPECIFIC AND I DON'T THINK THAT
THERE IS ANY FAULT OR SHAME IN
MAKING SURE THAT YOU HAVE A
CERTAIN KIND OF ODOR.
DONALD TRUMP PICKED MIKE PENCE
FOR SPECIFIC REASONS, WHAT DO I
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH?
WHITE EVANGELICALS, WHAT IS
MIKE PENCE FOR ME, WHITE
EVANGELICAL.
BUT YOU NEED TO GET ON BOARD
WITH THIS IS A THANKLESS JOB AND
I NEED TO MAKE IN MY OWN AND ADD
SOME FLAIR AND PIZZAZZ AND HAVE
A BETTER REPUTATION, AND SHE
NEEDS TO MAKE SURE THAT HE IS
SUPPORTING HER AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE.
I ACTUALLY THINK THAT HE DOES A
GOOD JOB OF DOING THAT.
>> Katie: WE ARE YOUR AND A
HALF AND, WHEN YOU THINK SHE
WILL START?
AS LONG AS SHE HAS A STAFF
BECAUSE EVERYONE IS LEAVING?
SPEWING ONE AFTER ANOTHER AFTER
ANOTHER AFTER ANOTHER.
HOW MANY IS LEFT?
13?
SOMETHING CRAZY.
AMERICANS ARE FORGIVING AND VERY
UNDERSTANDING.
IT IS ALMOST AS THOUGH WE COULD
LOOK BACK ON THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF AND SAY OKAY, MAYBE IT IS
JOE'S FAULT, I DON'T THINK IT IS
JOE'S FAULT, FOLKS.
SHE IS WHO SHE IS.
BUT I DON'T BLAME JOE.
I DON'T BLAME THE FACT THAT SHE
IS IN A POSITION OF
VICE PRESIDENT AND THEREFORE
IT'S A TOUGH JOB.
THAT IS NONSENSE.
YOU ARE A VIBRANT WOMAN AT THE
PRIME OF YOUR LIFE, YOU ARE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, YOU'VE GOT THE
ENERGY, YOU'VE GOT THE STAMINA.
YOU ARE QUICK, YOU'RE SHARP, YOU
HAVE RUN FOR OFFICE BEFORE.
YOU SHOULD BE OUT THERE EVERY
DAY DOING SOMETHING.
I DON'T CARE IF HE GAVE YOU THE
BORDER TO DEAL WITH.
YOU SHOULD BE OUT THERE GETTING
WOMEN TOGETHER, GETTING
BUSINESSPEOPLE TOGETHER, BABY
FORMULA, WHATEVER IT IS?
YOU GET OUT THERE AND YOU BE
HEARD.
DO NOT CONTROL BY JOE BIDEN, HE
DOES NOT TELL YOU WHAT YOU DO.
YOU CAN DO WHAT YOU WANT TO DO,
SO DON'T GET ME THIS GARBAGE
THAT JOE BIDEN IS NOT GIVING HER
A CHANCE.
SHE IS A LEGACY AND SHE IS NOT
INTERESTED.
THAT'S WHY SHE IS A FAILURE.
>> Katie: SHE HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AT ONE THING, GETTING
ON YOUR SHOW.
>> Greg: WE FIND OUT THAT SHE
IS QUITE IRRESISTIBLE IF YOU
SUPPLY BONGOS WHEN SHE TALKS,
BECAUSE SHE IS LIKE A BEAT POET.
I THINK JOE KNOWS THAT
KAMALA HARRIS IS THE BEST
DECISION HE EVER MADE, BECAUSE
NO ONE WANTS HIM TO GO ANYWHERE.
I PRAY FOR HIS HEALTH EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
BECAUSE THEN IT IS HER.
THE GOLDEN RULE OF BEING
PRESIDENT IS YOU, HE IS ALREADY
INCOMPETENT, SO THAT MAKES HER
ZERO INCOMPETENT.
AND WON'T FIND ANYBODY WORSE
THAN HER VP, EVERY CANDIDATE
WILL OUTSHINE HER.
AND IF SHE PICKS A BOX OF WET
WIPES, DECIDE THAT WE CAN HAVE
AN ULTIMATE OBJECT TO THAT IS VP
SO SHE CAN RUN, BUT BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL POINT THAT THERE IS NOT
A SINGLE PROBLEM SHE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO SOLVE WHETHER IT IS
CRIME, INFLATION, FENTANYL AND
THE NEXT BLOCK OR THE BLOCK
AFTER THAT, ALL OF THE EGGS ARE
IN THAT JANUARY 6 POLITICAL
BASKET, BUT THAT THEATER DID NOT
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE AND THEY
DID NOT CATCH ANY CRIMINALS.
AND PEOPLE SAW THROUGH THAT.
SO THEY ARE IN A BIND SO TO
SPEAK.
>> Jesse: JUST KIND I WOULD
ARGUE THAT WET WIPES ARE PRETTY
VALUABLE, GREG.
>> Jessica: THAT IS REALLY
ANNOYING.
IT'S BEFORE I DID THAT F